hallo klicks und hallo jan delay nicht
aber eine frage an dich freuen wenn sie
wir beantworten könntest und zwar
wirklich vor einiger zeit hier im
wunderschönen hamburg in der color line
arena mit udo lindenberg sinn gesehen
und fragen mich jetzt wie es zu diesem
date auf der bühne gekommen und wie ist
es mit der freundschaft gekommen die du
ja mit buden aufgebaut hast vielen dank
für die beantwortung der frage und damit
gewicht zu euch ja also dass das ding
mit udo ist ich musste erst mal am
anfang anfang also vor
das erste mal getroffen habe ich ihn 97
da wusste ich wusste er noch nicht wer
ich bin ich wusste gerade mal wer ich
bin und ich bin halt fan von ihnen seit
ich fünf jahre alt bin herr war der
erste zu mir der zu mir in einer deutsch
deutschen sprache in meiner sprache
gesprochen hat und auch mit wörtern die
ich benutzt habt wie ich heiß und
schauen was man nicht hat kohlen eine
geile musik gemacht und das war das
erste fan ding wo ich zu jemandem
aufgeschaut habe wo ich dachte wow das
ist der repräsentiert mich lange vorrat
und deshalb bin ich halt mein leben lang
ein glühender fan und dann habe ich ihm
97 als wir als bambule also die erste
große beginn hatte noch gar nicht
draußen war mal getroffen in hamburg
habe ich mit dynamite deluxe demo in die
hand gedrückt und mich vorgestellt und
nur dort
und dann haben wir uns das nächste mal
dann drei oder vier jahre später wieder
getroffen da war gerade mit der
mongolischen raus und meine reggae
platte searching und die hat er gehört
und gefeiert und das hat mich ganz krass
stolz gemacht so
meine freundin hat mir neulich erzählt
dass sie
zwei 2002 oder so weiß sie noch genau
weil oder jetzt auch immer in interviews
erzählt dass ich irgendwie einer seiner
besten freunde bin mir immer erzählt
dass damals so ein fax bei mir im zimmer
lag wo er geschrieben hat dass er die
garantie reggae platte gehört haben die
super geil findet und nicht für mich war
dass das allergrößte ich habe dieses fax
irgendwie behandelt wie eine insignie
quasi und von da an war für mich gleich
will irgendwann was mir die machen weil
ich sowieso als zitat habe ich ihn auf
jeder meiner platten drauf und dann
kamen mercedes benz meine erste frank
platte und da hatte ich da wusste ich da
muss ja mal drauf und dann hatte ich
dieses ins wunderschöne instrumental im
arsch und wusste da muss er immer drauf
habe ich den text geschrieben dass
geschickt und er fand das super und dann
haben wir uns das erste mal wirklich
richtig so getroffen also zusammen in
seinem zimmer im atlantik und ja und
seitdem sind wir halt irgendwie fast
unzertrennlich er damals auch sein an
sein neues album begonnen ich habe da
ganz viel geholfen und gezeigt und
gemacht und getan und seitdem machen wir
einfach ganz ganz viel zusammen ich
komme gerade mit ihm aus england wieder
ich war mit ihm fünf tage auf dem rock
liner na ja und genau so wie ich dann
bei ihm auf more kleiner mit form bei
ihm mit auftreten ist es damals auch so
wenn ich in hamburg spiele und er hat
zeit dann kommt er natürlich auch zu mir
und so kommt es dann zu einem spontan
stelldichein in der hamburger color line
arena um jetzt mal eine ganz lange
geschichte endlich zu beenden aber
natürlich ist die unsere gemeinsamen
geschichte noch lange nicht beendet